Okay.
Basically, I said module means
Basically, I said module means student module to the student
student module to the student information module.
student information system.
student list.
basic topics.
student module.
first login.
student.
student list.
All students present in our
All students present in our list.
student list.
student.
number of students.
institute.
screen.
2525 students.
student.
filter.
that means
specific category.
134.
student.
new student.
I'm going to put it on the screen.
in case.
Action. Action.
student.
profile picture.
same option.
there after.
basic details.
for example.
student.
default.
for example.
display name.
personal.
student.
option.
change.
number.
save.
student.
details.
transport.
assign.
for example.
system.
select.
by default.
assignment.
student.
subject.
complete details.
student.
this.
details.
student.
change.
edit.
save.
documents.
student.
for example.
document.
student.
both number series is auto-generated. Then admission number is our primary,
on which we can search the student. Thereafter, there is a roll number field,
you have to assign a roll number separately, you can see that here.
ID, student name, I am adding a student for myself. Basic date of birth, whenever you add,
while adding, if your pink line field is required, it means you have to add those details mid-day.
For example, if you have not added father qualification, mother qualification,
then you can also add students without any information.
For example, father name or mother.
The student that I have added is the one with the name of the tummy, 123456.
Apart from this, you have excel upload. You can also use excel upload in bulk.
First option is add student. From here, you can add students in bulk.
There is a sample file for this, sample means sample excel.
By downloading this sample excel and adding data to it, your student gets added.
If you have not filled the data before, then the student does not get added, it shows you the error.
You can add from excel, you can try it on your own.
You have to fill the same basic details in this as well.
Then we have after the student list, we have student list course wise as well.
Student list course wise. Now the student list that you have seen,
it has all the complete data.
Student list course wise.
For example, a teacher who is only a class 1 teacher, he has only class 1 data.
The main purpose was that if there is a class teacher, he only has to show his class to his students.
For that, we have student list course wise.
If you have any query, you can add a new student from here.
You have to export this data in excel. You can also export this data in excel by clicking on this.
Then we have the student certificates.
Student certificates basically in the institute, you can print the student's character certificate.
You can print his ID card, library card.
You can print all these certificates from here.
You have the option to search for a single student.
You can search by name.
By default, you can print all the certificates.
You can also use the same filter.
You can also give this certificate by entering the details.
By default, you have to enter the details.
You have to enter the details.
If you save from here, you can print it.
Then you have the option to print and inactive.
the student really were all right top it's a don't be auctioneers to print
that case at the strength of inactive bird for example massive popcorn print
that get the father to get yeah yeah yeah mara print this cop set that's up
there all right chicken is the rest of our DC certificate print that's a clear
yes from us a institute to have a certificate print that's a certificate
certificate student ledger has student ledger to get tuition fee certificate
we have coffee can you take a certificate up about that college
because we basically use with a student ID card admit card appreciation
certificate I did I did you just sit up with students gosh is there is a different
certificates rent a printer to get your student ID card at Institute student
certificate any option for bulk print let's say key case are they and would
you say I'm gonna get bit card one other guy let's look okay I think about they
go for example much enough bulk printer that many students selected a ginger
printer for example you just student Anna meeting student and in come on
bulk print bulk print up ID card because of the bulk map the cap renting
they go bulk makes a top ID card printer and you'll sit there in a bulk may admin
cut rate turn you'll sit there to go Sarah that yeah pass bulk me ID card
okay many team student select here the way bus three students going to get
selected okay yeah print option a new bulk print set table after I'm just a
character certificate have a sub-a put on a balcony then you'll take a CD a
mission teacher this year right so how many of the basic setup for the student
feedback to get enough quick entity because you can then I'm a student
feedback already set up a student feedback and then I'm a good basic set up
kind of this like you go to a student feedback after enable or check again to
Institute set up can't help it you can't pass that they have a student master
set up to get this kind of care out there up for a student feedback set up
a student feedback type or student feedback category to get to student
feedback type is there a couple student co-feedback dinner either positive
feedback or something negative feedback or something neutral or something to get
your drop-down Institute like a gate cry it's a positive feedback or something
negative or neutral ticket feedback that I thereafter feedbacking category
you will kiss category got feedback in a chart that's it back else at the
academy performance was up here and a sports host of that co-curricular
rose up there was a little bit more to do something for example they said that
we sports key academy key co-curricular use the level of yeah okay categories
was at the head drop student feedback within a clip and I said they're behavior
class behavior came in or I'm lucky just say behavior was up there I will
understand that to get three up the categories would have a basic set up
just that feedback set up a little bit to student feedback type or feedback
category you go to set up a feedback they guess is a teacher those capacity a
student can the fourth option of the student feedback to get this go Jesse
up open click karo game filter page on a poor chicken by default up a sorry
classes for data for example class monkey teacher co-student got feedback
this is student car feedback section and yeah has a feedback this up to date to
get feedback cut I tell yeah I'm poor title open up open the clear private
open private means go there for example you do feedback there you know man
student car many were open use key at the means other teachers will be a
student car feedback show feedback report of tears me to get all student
private means to the teacher data here or just the student is open private
coming yes yeah I'm a master when I am a student got feedback negative then I
had neutral then I have positive then I'm oh then poncy category got feedback
there you may look at mix key they know to get or manage if good feedback
description and attachment fine attachment up here so what that's good
to get then a person a kiss and notification that before it's coming in
get out there come on a password a student app I'm gonna take you yeah
just means to me happens we have just map operate cut to the except up not
data they accept you know up me free deposit because this is a gap with the
institute so student up me at pay up enough feedback they suck it to get to
notification
or a job feedback add to the student time when we show them up to pass
student list up a student list me just be sure and got feedback I don't know
what's the student key timelines except there's many student click yeah it's a
student time line up here to get this particular okay it's major job major
population here you go you have to ask them up here so they suck the up major
use the feedback at the update to get the feedback in the area student feedback
access at the answer so that's gonna be sick up the set up for them to get it
may in char options may actually be queries no matter you can't then how
scholar ID of the scholar I need to be a my pasta a can't eat a he is making a
student go home news keys caller ID said yeah that's all that an admission
number to go up a scholar ID system into actor up there to get to a mighty
scholar idea to get scholar ID update got a student under a classic option that
updates caller ID come here to get this papo click on it
student car data yeah just for example which is a student is caller I didn't
really update Karni a mess pick a movie at it yeah up a job you just kept
change Karni a more take a safer to me to a change of a chicken please ma'am
repeat come nice a query they will scholar ID out there student gonna
admission number up about our home student quite easy unique numbers a
actor there for example class one I was missing name give what sort of student
edit I didn't click on okay yeah I say I'll update go to a job you have to
then I say for the little data say go to a student and then you have to make a
update smaller I think it was scale our student got high to rate update gonna
will be happy I submit because of those simple I basically just a teacher I
you know teacher can't get that teachers roll numbers we update got the upper
butter over her a class can the teacher of me roll number update because of the
answer get up now height or weight students go update because of the
update height we have to click here up we asked me class like to turn here this
class kiss wouldn't have a bit when such a class fun yeah my section yeah section
naked look at okay so class a gap key yeah yeah data upload where we get my
bones a class kiss student around the details are here up move your job date
kind of skin you have to get another label select gonna keep music update
kind of height yeah wait for example move your weight update kind of many bits
student key details are we then we should update gather their music height update
can you student key to get here already updated is smell up in key so they go
it's no question you're a chip that many added details pick me I did pick
yeah three editable oh yeah check it update yeah or yeah ha ha pass bottom me
jessie up or they will a be up in a sara enter got a time to get then update
serial numbers in a select kind of a specific option I'll tell you update
obviously click on any update or drive up a successful message I'll get you up
make it a student stop date yeah yeah yeah hi to the great students he gets
them take the same in the data up go fetch kind of topics back so the best
speakers up to give us came back next time I pass that enrollment number or
rule number German student course I'm gonna be there yeah because a classman
under 50 students have those kids student you go roll over to me and tell
me to get the whole same class left curry class money can you give me a class
money can you pass list of it right after that editable new got that my edit
roll number pick me up as reset option that I for example which is class
clear a point same option excel
student list student list course wise certificates feedback or the which
updations admission number height weight roll number yes